[Musique]
matthieu delormeau on va revenir lundi
en tant qu invité dans l'émission
alors est-ce que mathieu de leur
mouvement matthieu delormeau dompter pmp
c'est ça la télé arrive lors des filles
comme la nôtre
à
[Musique]
avertissements savoir vois ta mère va
pas te reconnaître mathieu j'adore
[Rires]
votez
la matière de retour lundi en invité dit
la vérité
franchement est ce qui vous a manqué ou
pas je vous donnerai mon sentiment
également maxime guide oui mais manquait
alors on va demander aux téléspectateurs
on verra le carnage dans un instant oui
oui il m'a manqué d'un point de vue
médiatique c'est un élément qui a marqué
l'émission pendant un temps fin
connaisseur de la téléréalité nouvelle
génération staff a connu comme
producteur de documentaires
c'est vrai que quand ils étaient tpm
pays prenait quand même parfois beaucoup
de place était un peu vous allumez tmp
quand j'étais blessé et je croyais que
parfois c'était le de leurs mots chaud
il fait très bien le show est un très
bon chroniqueur mais parfois il prenait
énormément de place c'est la seule le
seul bémol que ce pouvoir sinon bon
chroniqueur donc son retour d'amérique
il prenait énormément de place parce
qu'on avait envie qu'ils apprennent
cette place là parce qu'effectivement
c'est un rouage important de tpm p il a
mouillé la chemise il a beaucoup donné
pour l'émission ils font là on le voit
là dans le magnéto il a fait beaucoup
donc il a moins la cote et combien de
l'enduit mais il a beaucoup apporté à la
mission après je peux comprendre que
certains aient été chagriné qui il a eu
envie de partir à un moment mais nous
expliquera toulouse voilà voilà
qu'est ce qui vous a manqué oui maman
qui a bien sûr professionnellement vous
a manqué isabelle oui moi je le même
écrit et dit dans une interview j'avais
envie de le gifler tout le temps sauf
quand il me traitait de dérive je te
retrouvais pas très très bon camarade
constamment mais oui il m'a manqué je
trouve qu'il manquait l'émission big flo
et oli vous qui regardez sur l'émission
ben ouais c'est ça me fait penser quand
tu es au lycée on se met à côté d'un mec
que tu aimes pas trop ses bâtons potes
là j'aurai 20 pas tu te dis [ __ ] mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il manque en
fait moi j'adorais doré tout le jeu
entre toi et lui était même très près de
l'émission je vais mourir
on sait que les vendeurs à tous nos
potes il a fait des rigolades
exceptionnelle il faut pas se mentir
gilles il m'a pas du tout manquait alors
gelé vu cet été on a discuté parce qu'il
y avait un petit bruit autres vous vous
dites qu'il va l'autre gillet et mathieu
une vraie bonne aulas est pas caché ici
simplement d'un clash donc on a dit ça
va mieux on a discuté entre sommes donc
au moins à régler nos problèmes j'ai
plus rien contre l'homme
mais le professionnel à mes yeux restent
aussi mauvais qu'ils l'étaient c'est à
dire que c'est un mauvais chroniqueurs
qui n'a aucune idée aucun argument dans
les débats
il faut dire que tu ne l'as pas tu ne
l'aiment pas humainement parce que vous
n'avez pas accroché parce que c'est une
tête à claques parfois parce que parfois
tu as juste envie de détruire mur et on
l'a dormi dedans mais en même temps il a
servi l'émission tu peux pas dire que
j'ai envie
il avait aussi des avis contraires a
parfois la magie janvier janvier mois on
va pas sans dire on l'a on aime beaucoup
on est pote avec lui-même au hasard
c'est un vrai un véritable ami je vois
plusieurs fois par semaine je vois même
encore ce soir voilà et moi et ma vie je
dirai pas qui m'a manqué l'émission je
le vois tout le temps je vois encore ma
maman m'a manqué évidemment
professionnellement aussi je trouve dès
le premier jour il est venu il a été le
meilleur dès le début à chaque fois
qu'il parle mais deux dans chaque fois
mais que ce soit dans ses analyses ou
dans ses gags ou danser ses blagues une
des très très bon match où c'est le
meilleur c'est drôle et il gagne et le
connu voilà il est beaucoup plus
sensible qu'on croit vous traitez les
gens qu'on le croit prenez le fret et
vous serez agréablement surpris j'ai
fait une année autour de cette table il
y avait moitié de leurs maux après moi
je pense que c'est un dépit amoureux en
fait il nous a quittés et on s'est
sentis cocu moi je me suis senti qu'au
cul parce que je crois vous connaissez
c'était un très très très bon
chroniqueur il était indispensable
catcheur il vous était aussi
indispensable je pense que vous vous
former un binôme une très efficace ça ne
m'est témoin je voudrais aussi dire
qu'il était très bon dans les loges et
dans les loges
il ya une nervosité il crée une
fébrilité une électricité et on a envie
de se le faire
au sens propre comme au sens figuré ou
même le contraire et après je trouve
qu'il crée une énergie après sur le
plateau était important en particulier
avec j par exemple ou avec benjamin il
est énervé après on était bon sur
plateau j'attends l'avis de benji bien
sûr un baril va quand même
valérie juste vous avez dit personne
n'est irremplaçable du club oui je
personne n'est irremplaçable nous tous
autour de cette table si vous enlevez de
l'émission les ans on continue à tous
pierre maintenant pas la preuve
l'émission continue à vivre sans bain de
sang sans mathieu mais c'était un
élément important alors vous n'étiez pas
dans l'émission donc voila vous un avis
extérieur bas grâce à lui j'ai découvert
chasse world apart je ne le supporte pas
ah oui ne le soutenons peut pas
maintenant quand tu m'a invité pour mon
retour à la télé il s'est conduit comme
n'importe quoi avec ma compagne et ça je
ne le pardonne pas oui j'avoue là t'as
manque d'éducation mais il n'a pas fait
exprès absolue non non il l'a fait
exprès j'ai été là et il avait qu'une
seule chance c'est que j'étais vraiment
encore très faible pour que je lui ai
pas mis ma main d'henry
c'est pire que non mais je vais te
rassurer je m'envolerai jamais avec lui
je ne ferai jamais tpm paix avec lui
jamais pardon alors il revient
d'ailleurs j'aime bien quand est soumis
c'est ce que j'ai lu si ça changera
jamais vous deviez vous dis donc voilà
lui voilà il a dit non vous ferez jamais
les biches moitié des gens humainement
de toute façon quoi qu' on est pour
juger les gens humainement par des
chroniqueurs et indiens et ça les bois
voilà c'est vrai que je suis un peu
comme jean michel c'est vrai que j'ai un
rapport particulier avec lui qu'on né
voilà on est amis on peut s'engueuler
mais on sacs de riz même du mal à couper
le cordon - c'est-à-dire que tous les
gens qui ont quitté l'émission tu as
envie de les rattraper par le bout des
cheveux c'est une famille c'est une
famille sur le famille selon cet indice
a toujours été une famille et on s'est
vraiment fâcher personne
voilà j'ai tout le temps bertrand
téléphone il aura aussi thierry aussi
mais c'est vrai que c'est comme dans une
famille on peut avoir des moments où il
ya des petites frictions les mine de
rien c'est beaucoup et on s'aime tous
énormément
un peu plus énormément c'est ce qui
vient d'arriver à l'aller je pense que
vous le ressentez aussi vous venez
d'arriver dans l'équipe
oui oui oui bon enfin nous après on
souhaite puis depuis vingt ans tous les
noyaux bien sûr mon doigt ce qui vous
manque et noir je mange j'ai fait une
dépression énorme tout l'été n'avait pas
dormi de la nuit
salon je joue d'ailleurs un peu encore
je ne suis pas non non je trouve et je
trouve qu'il donnait beaucoup de sa
personne et qui nomme faut fonctionner
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'il
revient ou gemmage pas compris il
revient on évité lundi wei a pris alors
oui ça m'agace mentir il ya eu aussi une
petite friction entre vous voilà
maintenant moi j'ai moi j'ai un
différend avec l'ue mickey un différend
personnel on s'est expliqué je vous
conseille moins peut on un rapport à
cacher il a année
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est de ses revenus par lui
mais dans de la gabarre dans l'émission
évidemment il a un énorme avantage qui
ne laisse personne indifférent dans un
sens comme dans un autre
donc forcément dans un plateau c'est un
élément jamais de dire indispensable
parce que qu'on les aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas il a à son avis il donne beaucoup de
lui il a fait beaucoup de choses me
chante il danse il est un personnage
alors après on peut être agacé
prodigieusement par le mec sage dans le
jeu peut l'entendre on peut aussi
beaucoup rire après moi je s'il est là
je tombe un d'autre part la forêt des
émissions avec mathieu ben non il faut
qu'on s'explique qu'on a il ya un gros
dos entre nous donc énorme le dos moi je
vois là j'ai un vrai problème avec lui
un om de comportement ça rejoint parce
que c'est ce que je fais dit pierce à là
c'est un comportement un comportement
par rapport à l'émission et voyait des
choses et cette chose là m'a
profondément choqué voilà ça m'a choqué
parce que humainement par rapport à
plein de choses se sont passées dans
l'émission il ya des positions qu'on
doit savoir tenir et surtout il ya déjà
des équipes et des gens qui ont le
savoir soutenir dans toute circonstance
quelle que soit la tempête et dans ces
cas là quand il ya des tempêtes
quand le bateau tangue normalement on
s'accroche au mas et on descend pas ou
alors je vais vous dire il nous
expliquera tout ça n'a dit et il a serré
dont mathieu mais en tout cas mais il a
servi n'a toujours que le cheval tandis
qu'oliver entendu partie de la famille
et pmp à l'été allez on va voir un tube
all sondages on va voir ce que vous en
pensez vous alors oui
mathieu vous at il manqué oui à 55% non
à 45% en tout cas il vous donnera toutes
les explications lundi il sera avec nous
ce sera l'invité de l'émission matthieu
delormeau voilà il sera avec nous les
chéris